all right so in honor of this episode we
are going to stay in this position the
whole entire time this is still thank
you I couldn't turn my head to look at
the screen this is still which opens
with a picture of them as statues which
has nothing to do with anything except
that statues are still and the
butterflies and there was a butterfly in
there so that connects this is an
episode where Finn and Jake wake up
frozen exactly like in this position in
their sleep and it's the Ice King is in
our Ice King episode and he is frozen
them and won't unfreeze them until he
deems them friends like good friends and
they have to match his criteria which
includes impersonating one another
sharing like slumber party stories about
girls and watching horrible slideshows
of his photography most of them of
Gunter who's a little bitch in this
episode by the way like all he does is
try to knock over the bottle that can
unfreeze them it's like there's no
reason why nothing Goethe has ever done
in the past indicates he's like it's
really bizarre and while that's going on
Finn tries to contact opposite Co the
Austral beast the Astro beast like his
astral beast his Astro beast yeah it's a
trick dogs just butterflies but it works
okay because the butterflies there's a
lot of them and they pick them up and
try to fight the ice king but they bring
in the wrong potion he gets frozen and
then when they try to get Gunther to
unfreeze them he knocks it over and does
the little dance but say I mean he
doesn't sing about punching buns that
was a very similar dance so it's it's
fine I think you get you get a touch
more insight into the ice game just how
lonely he is I mean now it's not even
like kidnapping princesses is just
getting friends in general just really
sad and his idea of what he thinks
having friends is about and how he kind
of connects it to suffering like he kind
of know
was his photography is boring you suffer
through this and and he makes omelets
with his foot in it and stuff sights so
therefore when they eat part of him will
be in them yes it is pretty nasty but
funny as well so uh it's good it got
some good laughs and I don't know if
they're gonna be it won't be played the
next episode actually woke with them
later opened up with them like still
being frozen I would like to see what
where there's not like it's not like a
two-parter it just actually picks up
exactly where it left off with that
being frozen that would be pretty funny
um but yeah it's got some good laughs
it's funny I mean not a ton to say about
it but you know it's a decent episode
how about you frozen Jason who the sucks
my neck hurts um nobody actually
completely agree for the most part I did
like when the Ice King is saying what's
my favorite color and they have no idea
the ice King's like I know a lot about
you and they're kind of surprised with
how much exactly like the personal stuff
he knows like he stalks them pretty well
yeah I do like what he tells Jake like
you know you hold your emotions as why
you never cried like it's okay let it
out Jake just lets out this one single T
like he doesn't say anything or make it
say a page he just he still froze it
just with one tear fall so that yeah I
also really like or I guess more and
disturbed by than like the one scene
where Gunther gets free of his chains
and he goes after the bottle and the Ice
King puts him next to Jake when he
starts messing with Jake if you notice
he starts humping Jake's face yeah I
wasn't sure if I saw that right either
hold on who could it be he was pecking
his face cuz that's sort of what I
thought like he was moving his head back
and forth but because he's such a small
creature his body was kind of moving
with it uh I took it more so humping of
the face he did will come fish yeah
again for the kids watching maybe it was
just pecking the face who knows um you
know ghosts keep their heads cut off too
and it's
and also like how uh the ice king
dressed as Jake or as fan and then when
he's about to change into Jane now god
that was awesome I like I was underwear
is so bizarre to the I see it's like all
these weird bandages and stuff
he's like one quarter of the mummy yeah
I also ate something I am noticing
watching more and more of these is that
you know I used to associate John
DiMaggio yeah I used to associate his
voice almost entirely with bender and
it's almost exactly the same voices
bender but now I'm also seeing much more
with Jake now whenever I hear this voice
I'm not thinking oh that's bender
talking now I am thinking Jake like if
you just played a recording I would yeah
so see with that now too so that's kind
of nice you know I like bender fine but
it is funny how I'm now before I could
hear nothing but bender every single
dogs and now it's like I can hear
nothing but Jake so that's kind of nice
you know how the transition did
eventually happen well I go back and
re-watch some advanced Futurama episodes
and instead of hearing bender I know
here Jake yeah I think I think the
reason I pray you're at now are the one
thing I do like a little bit more about
Jake they do bender even though bender
is very funny is that Jake very much
will just sort of do so much randomness
and it's all for fun you know he'll just
make up a song or make up a word or say
sir whatever you want because it's just
kind of fun you know and it's what's
wrong with having fun there we're at
bender it's like he's a party animal too
but he's like he can't has fun hurting
people also I'm putting him in misery
yeah just kind of an ass yeah and he's
got kind of big ego and stuff like that
so you know which is funny but I do find
myself liking Jake more so there you go
do it I don't know who would win in an
epic rap battle but there it is
any closing words before your arms fall
off no okay I'm gonna turn off the
camera go for it
good luck I will summon my astral beast
that will beast
come to me
hmm but they didn't so good okay no look
crap they can't do anything